hi I'm Rachel and one time in high
school I fainted on the bust and pissed
myself
did anybody else in school ever know or
like you just oh yeah and then I
remember like somebody came up to me and
like had called me like a Xanax horror
that's hard I'd never had like somebody
say something like that to me little
missy pissy pants maybe that was my
senior year nickname hi my name is Amani
and one time when I was 16 I pooped my
pants on a neighborhood walk was it like
kind of the runny kind sorry I gotta no
I need to know this it didn't have
enough cohesion to just sit nicely like
a little like Stone in my pants it was
like I'm gonna come down where gravity
takes me splatter a splatter hi my name
is Jake and I got punched in the face
over a muffin I went to get a snack a
little Snack Shack kitten from me bought
a muffin kids behind me broke out in a
fight bumped me into the kid in front of
me who dropped the muffin he turned on
and punched me in the face I see he was
mad that I made him drop as much all
right we've got peed